but I'm just curious or and other than
films like smiley and then your film
along roadside how many other
independent films can you name that have
YouTube stars as their you know sort I
honestly I don't know that's a great
question and I was looking into it just
trying to you know find who else is on
to this you know and I look up the list
of youtubers who are you know have great
followings and I can't find anything on
on IMDb as far as project in development
or in production of post-production or
completed I honestly I'm a bit surprised
so I don't know who's you know didn't I
I didn't know what about smile either oh
right with Shane Dawson and told Turner
oh I met Toby oh you did he was at the
moms birthday few days ago hello oh ok
well let's talk about Iman it's eman
croissant yeah and how did he become
involved with along the roadside well he
heard about the script from one of the
other guys who was cast in the film
Daniel grossly true is a man behind
gradual report that's not a YouTube
channel his following is pretty hardcore
he calls his fans at lemon drops in and
they're pretty awesome i kept some of
them that came to the screening in
europe at the premiere and knew someone
like drove him from amsterdam to see him
its sting is real you know and anyways
he member teamollie one of those YouTube
gatherings i think it was in June last
year and he told him look this movie I'm
in and they're looking for some black
people apparently that's what he thought
and he was like hi so he sent in the
script I read the script and then he
sent me a script I'm he emails like
really wanting to be a part of this no
no okay what send an audition and that's
what really got me on Tori I want to
meet this guy he's not because his
edition was really well done not so much
the acting alone although it was great
but he cut it he put music to it he shot
it with three cameras I mean it's nearly
made a little short film about it which
you
for me like this guy wants to be there
who wants to be on the set and you want
those people and we were in the middle
of negotiating with a Hollywood actor
actually answer the whole thing started
shifting
you